Now let's dive into the THI dashboard,
which provides tailored insights for two
key personas,
property managers and market leaders.
This solution is built to empower both
roles with actionable data that drives
better decision making across different
levels of operations.
At the property level,
managers can filter tenants by risk
categories high, medium and low.
For instance,
clicking on the High Risk filter
transforms the dashboard to show tenants
who pose greatest financial risk.
This includes tenant who have occurred at
years over a significant.
With key metrics such as overdue amounts
and the probability of default.
Here you can see an example of a tenant
with an overdue balance and high default
probability.
This insight allows property managers to
focus their efforts on tenants who are
more likely to default,
helping them to prioritize follow-ups and
mitigate risk.
At a broader level,
market leaders can access strategic
insights by analyzing trends across
entire portfolios.
The dashboard allows them to review total
properties in a specific region,
tenant areas, and invoice amounts,
providing a real time snapshot of
financial health.
For example,
let's take a look at the New York market
where we can see a breakdown of high risk
tenants across multiple properties.
Market leaders can view the overall
portfolio risk,
track how much the total invoice amount
is at risk,
and identify areas that require immediate
attention.
Market leaders can use this information
to engage with property managers,
guiding them to focus on specific
properties or tenants that are most
vulnerable.
This Birds Eye view market leaders to
benchmark performance,
allocate resources more effectively and
ensures that risks are managed
proactively.
It provides them with a competitive
advantage by allowing them to focus on
portfolios with the highest risk while
maintaining visibility over the entire
market.
By combining these detailed views for
property managers and high level insights
for market leaders,
the THI dashboard ensures that CVRE teams
can act swiftly to mitigate risks,
improve tenant relationships and enhance
portfolio performance.
We have made significant strides with the
development of the Tenant Health Index
through an iterative Sprint based
approach.
The Senior's Shield faces focused on
model development and validation.
By Sprint 3 enabled was able to predict
the probability of default and by Sprint
5 we've added the capability to predict
errors.
Looking forward,
the major milestones is the release of
MVP One in November,
which will introduce the tenant risk
category feature and pulse
functionalities for onboarding.
This will enable us to categorize tenants
into risk buckets and provide more
granular insights.
Further enhancements are planned for MVP
2 in early 2025,
which will incorporate external data
sources and additional pulse features.
Thank you for your attention,
and I hope this demo has provided a
clearer understanding of how the Tenant
Health Index can help transform the way
we manage tenant risk and portfolio
performance.